check out this week's must-see movies  juice super-powered former allies battle  each other and then must team up to  protect civilization in thor ragnarok  [Music]  a night owls life changes after a young  woman's car breaks down in Battle Creek  you know what amazes me about you could  be anything I'm a pretty amazing guy  three former military friends reunite in  last flag flying I'm taking Larry home  be there for your brothers that's all I  really matters see what's hot in  theaters with this week's fantasy  patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]